you did post some pictures with charlie
jordan
where you yeah poking or like what was
that that was that was a joint yeah
those were her her rose petal
joints it was like uh it was a brand
shoot
okay okay because you got there's a lot
of things in the comments about
isn't she dating taylor yeah the caption
the caption was uh
what was it i forget what i said don't
worry taylor it's just for the pictures
or something like that
it was a funny caption okay so nothing
that fans should be
worried about no no no you know the next
topic i'm going to bring up
i'm sure what is it addison
oh yeah oh yeah i'll keep it short but i
did talk to her recently
she's lovely no she yeah she's dope
she's lovely i won't talk about addison
or anything through all this but who
broke up with who
uh i ended it you did reveal recently
that you were the one to break up with
her
jeff completely cut out the second part
it was like that i didn't even think
that was going to make the video he was
just like who broke up with who
and then i said yeah i broke up with her
no i'm just kidding she
broke up with me but he cut that out i
didn't even realize but it was funny
so you weren't the one to break up with
him it was i wouldn't even say like
either
either one of us broke up with each
other like one of us saying like this is
this is done it was like kind of mutual
it was both of us agreed yeah
when when was the last time you guys
talked are things still very friendly
between you two are you
yeah yeah we're still really good
friends uh last time i talked to her
though probably like a few days ago
okay so things are like yeah yeah we
don't talk on a
daily basis but yeah yeah is it hard to
see how much the fans still ship you
guys
no i think addison and i were
really good together and i think we we
impacted a lot of people's lives and we
appreciate that
it's not like we did that and then we're
saying all right guys you you can't have
these accounts anymore
we started it go for it
do you ever see you guys getting back
together or no because you did tweet you
were like i wish you the best with all
your future relationships
getting back together i don't know i
mean we'll we'll see
we'll see okay there were some other
romance rumors
you and tessa that's a no
we're just friends me and her we're just
friends when we were tipsy like we had
like a few drinks
like we both looked at that was like
what the heck
are you kind of looking then to stay
single for a little bit and like focus
on yourself
i'm just going with the flow okay you're
not dating anyone right now that we're
gonna hear about
tomorrow no no no if the right person
comes along like what are you looking
for
a great sense of humor would would be
appreciated because some of my humor is
really dry
and if you don't think i'm funny then
we're not going to work
so fake laugh at my jokes what did you
think about addison getting cast in the
remake of she's all that that's insane
i'm super proud of her
that's that's a big thing that's a big
deal i know she's she's really
passionate about it
i'm proud of her you've had a kind of
crazy couple of months you had the
breakup you turned
21. what do you feel like you've learned
about yourself
that 21 is going to be a crazy year i
feel i definitely need to work on
not being as problematic why do you feel
like you're probably because
it does come acro i feel as if i'm a
really nice guy but
when i do these sarcastic remarks online
about other influencers and stuff it
does make me seem like an ass
so i'm gonna chill out on that i'm 21
now i don't need to worry about these
people
you